as you see herman take the bound he has
struggled against the braves a 7 56
career era and four starts so he's
always motivated and he's even more
motivated tonight to put some zeros up
this is tap slowly to third bare hand
play out at first oh man what a play
that was by mcmahon what a play by ryan
mcmahon
as good as it gets it really is you see
it takes a funky hop goes to his right
use your bare hand throw off balance i
mean this is something you do in your
backyard that is incredible and now
first and third one down for austin
reilly he's been the hottest hitter for
atlanta on the road trip seven for 19.
and a high chopper
one play it's to first riley gets a
roller and an rbi albee scores to make
it one nothing
give riley his 84th rbi frame it is
second now they're two outs now looking
for a two out base hit for the birthday
boy
with a pitch on the way and he rockets
one down the left field line of base hit
all the way to the wall
adam cruising into second freddy will
score and the birthday boy gets it down
here on the top of the first inning but
rbi double to make it two-nothing
atlanta it's ian anderson versus the
rockies jeff and coors field yeah first
time at coors field we saw wascari noah
for the first time at coors field ian
last time against a giant so five and
two thirds four hits no runs facing
garrett hampson
as a bunt try riley sniffs it out bare
hand throw to first and the stretch by
freeman want to play
two great plays at the hot corner in the
first inning tonight and none better
than riley's it was almost like austin
riley read hampson's mind if you saw by
the time you saw that ball go down chip
he was full sprinted to home cj crone
the reigning player of the month in the
national league for august cj hitting at
275
sends a drive to center field peterson
running back and he runs out of room
touch him all time
cj krohn
into the center field bleachers
it's a 2-1 atlanta lead
he really
makes it look easy doesn't he when he's
going well
cj crone with such a smooth stroke but
generates so much power first and third
one out let's see if one of the better
hitting pitchers in the game can help
himself airmon marcus
good here comes mcmahon and
he won't play for freddie freeman so
well done herman
gets the bunt down the squeeze works and
the rockies have tied it up
there's only looking for a second base
into the ball game
swing and a high fly ball deep right
center field that one is gonna go
he'll walk around the bases
25 homers for albies
and that is a record-setting shot in
colorado all four infielders jeff have
25 or more homers now it's amazing and
now a 65th extra base hit charlie
blackman to step in one for one with a
single to right here goes the runner
this ball is driven to center field this
one way back this one is way down
homer at night for charlie blackman
against his hometown team no less
two-run shot puts the rockies in front
four to three
charlie now more than 190 homers in his
rockies career
seventh old time and
that was
right down colfax
time run 90 feet away for the braves one
ball one strike for solaire
smoked up the middle braves have tied it
up another big hit for jorge soler how
many times jeff has he done that
continues to just come up big with great
at bats and riley's coming up with two
on and two out here it is
got him
that ball was cutting away from austin
riley but the braves get it tied second
and third no one out in the sixth well
this one of the perfect guys to have up
right now
high contact rate with the infield back
in a 4-4 game with rymel tapia
and ravel hits this ball well to center
field
should be deep enough
peterson will wheel and throw to third
rockies take a 5-4 lead as mcmahon
scores
really good at back for ryan topia two
outs that'll bring up hamson 2-2
and a base hit to left
diaz gets a green light here's the throw
by duval ella gets past him
and hanson is on his way to third
six for colorado rockies up six to four
and here is trevor story this is hit
towards right field down the line fair
ball and into the corner platform speeds
around second he's gonna get the green
light around third story digging for
three no throw home rbi triple for
trevor story
7-4 rocky now the bases are loaded for
dansby swanson oh for three tonight
swung at the first pitch and skies it
into center
hampson is under he makes the grab and
freeman is gonna chug home
colorado concedes the run
it's a seven five games riley at second
duvall at first two outs a run in and
now the dangerous jock peterson
got him robert stevenson comes on and
short circuits the rally one down here
tonight
travis darneau is up and hits a high fly
ball deep left field one pitch and gone
fifth home run for darneau and now it
gets real interesting seven six here
come the braves down a run so it's up to
jorge soleil here's the oh what
in the air to right this should do it
charlie coming on he's got it and the
rockies have won on this saturday night
seven to six over the braves
they've won two of the first three
all three ball games one run affairs
tyler kinley
he gets the victory tonight
steve has another save
and the rockies can celebrate charlie
blackman
a home run in his third consecutive ball
game
herman got to start it's up in five
innings giving up four runs two of those
runs were unearned
but again the rockies at home so tough
they improved to 45 and 23 at coors
field